what you were saying is that you guys
don't do debt you got yes or no debt or
you use less debt than a pickle private
equity firm yes so so the SBA was on the
first transaction I did not you don't do
sp my own money that we have no we have
no involvement with banks or the SBA or
anything like that now I'm guys just do
cash deals you say here's ten million
bucks we're done why don't you use debt
yeah well so that's one way to take a
good company make it a fragile company
you know the more debt you're layering
on and the sort of the wider the
variation of outcomes that you expect to
happen and obviously pandemic risk is
something that was not a lot of people's
radars us included until recently but
it's a you know it's a good example of
why we think that not levering these
companies especially in the beginning
when you're starting to get to know them
I mean until you own these companies you
just don't know what you're getting
really until you get you know underneath
the hood and there's always more risk
there than you think there will be right
so you know our our mentality has been
going with with all equity no debt try
to keep them very very robust on the
balance sheet and make sure and we're
buying these with full balance sheets
attached to them right so working
capital is all included so the net worth
of the company will be you know fairly
robust going into the transaction and
then of course as we overtime as we
build cash into these companies then we
can decide what to do with it
but working capital bucket is kind of
like them you got to fill up the bucket
first right the owners can get anything
out right you gotta keep the the
machinery lubricated
[Music]